It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa.
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you for joining us today for our 132nd episode!
Why is the 3 in front of the 2 the single 1, 2, 3, huh?
We were just there and now it's going high.
Right.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, are you awake?
Yeah!
It's the beginning of a new week, so wake up!
Wake up!
Well, hopefully for those that are awake,
And maybe those that are awake and joining us for the first time today.
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
Oh, that means FUWAMOCO.
And it's hosted by us!
FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag!
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
Did I say Ruffians?
What if I don't want to wake up?
Ruffians that are awake but I thought it was the ones that are still asleep.
They don't want to wake up right now.
So how are you watching FUWAMOCO Morning?
In your dreams?
You want to go back to sleep?
I don't know who works like that, Moco-chan.
Ruffians.
This is Mococo.
In your dreams.
Speaking directly to you.
What are you going to do speaking directly to us like that, Moco-chan?
Huh?
What am I going to do?
I will tell you.
Use the hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING.
Look at all these Ruffians up there.
Subscribe to FUWAMOCO.
FUWAMOCO Is this supposed to be hypnosis or something, Moco-chan?
No, this is a dream.
That's all.
But the howl of a wolf is gonna wake up.
I'm not in charge of that.
That's not my place, okay?
WAKE UP!
FUWAMOCO!
Last night I'm lighting off on the right paw, Moco-chan.
Right?
Ibaru!
Yeah!
And...
Ruin that right paw.
We have bad news.
Why does it have to start like this every time, Moco-chan?
Can't we just, like, not have bad news?
Bad news.
There's been... Pero Sighting.
What about, like, a Pon-de-ring Sighting?
That would be good!
Why?
But that's not what we get.
The Ruffians and their Pero Sighting.
Yeah.
So we need to report on them.
Let's take a look then.
Well!
Our Pero Sighting is... De-den!
Garbage!
All I see is garbage!
How did Pero end up here, huh?
Well, maybe.
The garbage smelled a lot like some pudding, huh?
Yeah?
I don't know, have you ever smelled any pudding that smells like garbage?
Or garbage that smells like pudding?
Ruffians.
Pudding that smells like garbage!
I've smelled strawberries that smell like garbage.
I've smelled pudding that smells like garbage.
Not yet.
But garbage that smells like pudding.
Maybe.
No.
I don't know, maybe Pero finally got the message and that's why he decided to join the garbage.
Maybe.
What do you think, Ruffians?
They push the button and come back to it.
Push the button.
Push.
Press the button.
BAU BAU!
She wants it.
Let's push it!
Yeah!
But, Ruffians... I guess a Ruffian's a woman, but... It's not gonna do much, you know?
It's not gonna do anything.
Yeah...
You know, you saw our 3D debut, right?
Right!
Yeah!
You know, Pero is squishy and stretchy, so, uh, compacted.
You're not really gonna do much to him.
No, at the most, it'll just make a silly sound, but, uh... Yeah.
You know.
Yeah.
Oh, that's gonna happen.
I know!
It's disappointing.
No!
Yeah.
That's all that's gonna happen.
I guess that's okay.
You know, it's probably in there for a good reason, right?
Right!
Yeah.
We'll get them next time.
I believe that.
You know, there's a good reason, but... BAU BAU!
It's good to know where he is.
Always good to keep an eye out, okay?
No, I'm kinda curious.
I wanna go smell that garbage.
Why don't you just smell pudding that smells like garbage instead?
Why don't you just smell pudding?
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO fans!
A new week has started, but there's a bunch of exciting things going on!
Let's get sharing them with you right now!
Well, just earlier yesterday, Advent's very own gem of emotion, Koseki Bijou, or Biboo, she released the
Special music video for her first original song.
Prism Magic or Prism no Mahou!
BAU BAU!
Congratulations Biboo!
Congratulations!
BAU!
Did you see Ruffians?
Did you watch?
You know all the music is done by you, yeah?
Amazing.
And then the video!
The art and the animation was all done by Yunarin and Mio!
It's so amazing!
And you haven't watched it!
Oh, you need to go and watch!
It just came out so... You're still in time, but in it you know you get to see a prism of different magical girls!
Beautiful!
So cute!
And bright!
And maybe there's a...
Oh, yes!
But you know, I saw some people saying it was like watching a whole season of a magical girl anime just summarized up into one perfect original song here!
Yeah!
Oh, you really like the lily of the valley design too, yeah!
It's so cute!
There's so many beautiful things with the animation, the illustrations, it fits so well with Biboo's song too!
Very relaxing.
Right!
Yeah, seven seasons in one night!
So please, please go check it out!
And listen to it once too!
I believe it will be on streaming services very soon!
Full animation live!
Right!
Please, please go check it out!
Support Biboo and listen to it once!
As you know, maybe you can put it in a playlist together with Born to be BAU too!
Please listen to our song!
BAU BAU!
Yeah!
I wonder what Prism no Mahou and Born to be Baudel mashup would sound like, huh?
Now I'm thinking about... Say my name.
Say my name in baudel!
N-E-R-I-S-S FUWAMOCO!
Took you that long.
I think you're thinking really hard there, huh?
Yeah.
It's one of those times when you need to think really, really hard, okay?
I don't know, maybe the ultimate mashup.
Kumikyoku.
Prism No Mama.
Born to be BAU.
Don't say my name, right?
Yeah.
I don't know, that's a lot of different songs all together.
I think it could be good.
Please check it out over there!
BAU BAU!
F.U.W.A.M.O.C.O.
Ow!
Hi Ruffians!
It's a new week so we shared a new schedule with you just a little while ago.
But on it, this week we're having our very first off collab together with a very special person.
The amazing Suwapato!
FUWAMOCO Morning!
She's also an amazing ASMRtist, singer, and super cute demon king!
And very very good game choice too!
Finally!
I'm watching her live ASMR right now!
This is FUWAMOCO Morning.
Yeah!
Hatora-onee-san's so amazing!
We really really admire her and you know, finally we get to have our first collab all together and an all collab too!
So we're gonna be answering some questions, some marshmallows all together and chatting about a bunch of different things!
Yeah and if you're curious about marshmallows, it's a service where you can ask us questions but in the waiting room for this stream, there is a link
To the marshmallow box.
It's not open yet, but it will be soon, so please feel free to ask questions, okay?
I'm so excited, but I'm a little nervous too, right?
But on this, I'm so cute, so... I see a lot of questions about a certain topic.
Questions are for later, Ruffians!
Not right now!
Ask any questions, okay?
Yeah.
Can I ask a good question?
Yes, you can ask a good question.
FUWAMOCO will do her best to translate you, so... Use the way, okay, Ruffians?
It's part of the thread, sister!
We have a lot of sisters, Ruffians.
How many sisters do we have?
I've lost track.
Sisters.
Even in Spanish, unfortunately we cannot translate from Spanish to English to Japanese.
That's a little bit difficult.
Especially when we don't understand Spanish.
Understand Spanish.
Yeah.
I don't understand this.
BAU BAU!
I hope that you'll join us in FUWAMOCO!
We have a lot of different streams coming up this week.
The most exciting one is 7 Days to Dawn.
FUWAMOCO Hi!
FUWAMOCO Now you know our off call with Patreon is such a... FUWAMOCO But!
FUWAMOCO But when we shared our schedule with you regionally, FUWAMOCO There's a ?
FUWAMOCO Channel!
FUWAMOCO And well, that's a very good reason because... FUWAMOCO Now we can share with you Ruffians!
This upcoming weekend, FUWAMOCO will be participating in a special organized stream all organized by Mia-senpai called Houshou Marine Brain Battle.
Dream called dog.
How you doing?
What does dog mean?
Brain battle?
Brain battle.
As participants, we have to pretend to be a part of Mighty Senpai's brain and battle it out together to solve some of her very deep worries and concerns.
Sounds silly.
No, this is very serious.
It's solving for constraints.
Yeah, you know, it's like multiple parts of our mind are all coming together to solve the problem kind of thing, you know?
Like that!
Good stuff!
So, you know, FUWAMOCO, we have to make sure we do a convincing job of proving that we are actually minding the brain, otherwise we'll be found and voted out of the brain.
Fubuki-senpai, Subaru-senpai, Miyu-senpai, Okayu-senpai, and others will also be participating!
What do you think, Ruffians?
Do you think we'll be able to do a good impersonation of Marine-senchou-senpai?
I kinda hope we get it together.
Kinda like Inside Out.
I think that's kinda the idea.
Although I don't really know what that movie is.
No.
Yeah, Fuwawa could do it!
BAU BAU!
I'm not gonna share my impersonation right now.
Because that would be a little bit of a spoiler.
And it's probably really, really bad right now.
Right, Moco-chan?
You don't understand Spanish?
I don't understand Spanish.
Miya-senpai said that it was about 2 or 3 years in the works.
We're really really excited to be a part and you know, hopefully we can show just how fluffy and fuzzy that this part of Marine-senchou-senpai's brain is.
We're gonna have a bunch of fun and we're also gonna do our best as the sole members of hololive English.
We're gonna do our best!
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO's impersonation will be legendary!
Mococo's voice sounds exactly like mine, Senchou-senpai!
So happy that it seems like everybody's rooting for me!
BAU BAU!
I'm sure Moco-chan will do amazing!
I'll do my best.
I'll do my best too!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
Something surprising showed up in our mailbox.
Summer is over.
It's over.
A really really big box.
We opened it.
It turned out it was our prizes from the Holosummer Bingo!
Yeah!
FUWAMOCO, we worked really hard at the Holosummer Bingo.
We filled up both the regular bingo sheet and the infernal bingo sheet.
Both each 100% clear.
Thank you.
Consolation.
Yeah!
Let's take a look at what we received!
Oh!
What is this?
FUWAMOCO!
A consolation prize with something actually really really nice!
Some Megarhythm!
A Megarhythm makes a lot of really nice relaxing products.
Got earmuffs!
We got some hot earmuffs to put on her.
Tired eyes at the end of the day. And we really like using those usually!
We actually just ordered a bunch more so it's a little bit interesting timing. But we also got some nice shoulder heating patches too. And some nice bath salts too!
Lit cooling pads!
And well, of the Megarithms, we have over 100 of each!
We have a lot!
We have a lot, a lot, a lot.
A lot, a lot, a lot.
Cuz it was one month for each of us.
Fuwamon store.
Wow.
It's a lot.
A big box!
So, FUWAMOCO is going to be relaxing quite a bit.
That would be nice.
And there's so many nice baths we can have.
We got a really huge thing of fancy bath salts times two.
But what is the food there, huh?
Yeah, wow.
Also, we're surprised.
So Kanata-senpai, she won a year's supply of big katsu, which is like a katsu snack.
A little dagashi.
Yeah, but a year's supply?
A year's supply.
That's a lot!
So Kanata-senpai decided that she'd share!
She's gonna share it!
So we got a whole bunch of big katsu too!
A whole bunch!
Yeah!
I don't know if we can... Can we eat the whole guy?
Right.
At first I thought they were fast.
Big katsu.
Big katsu is good too, but bad lettuce and big katsu are a bit different, you know?
One fills my tummy, the other fills my heart.
But now we have lots of goodies!
And we can relax with our eye masks in the bathtub while eating big katsu!
Exactly!
Yeah, you know.
FUWAMOCO Have you tried eating a foul-littered door?
Moco-chan sneezed on a few for sure.
FUWAMOCO I didn't!
Moco-chan sneezed on a
Yeah, I don't know about eating a big katsu in the bathtub but maybe- KAKIGORI!
Yes.
Maybe you could eat the big katsu while like hanging out the outside of the bathtub!
Nice baths.
Relaxation.
And big cuddles and waiters in the future.
BAU BAU!
We're so lucky huh?
We're Ruffians.
Actually.
We thought we surprised you Ruffians.
FUWAMOCO!
We have a big announcement!
BAU BAU!
Oh, a big announcement in FUWAMOCO Morning!
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh.
Ruffians!
It finally happened!
Something that you've been looking forward to for a long time.
Which Ruffians, you know what the thing you've been looking forward to for a long time is, huh?
Mococo Hinata!
Doggycon!
That makes me happy though.
Oh!
New outfit!
Balls!
We got FUWAMOCO!
FUWAMOCO!
It's taking us a little while, you know.
Very busy demon doors.
But we finally were able to find exactly the FUWAMOCO that we were searching for all day!
You know, Ruffians do that.
FUWAMOCO's having a little bit of a hard time finding bowls.
We went to many different places.
We asked, do you have bowls?
And they'd be like, oh the bowls are this way.
And they're little voice bowls.
No, I don't want ocha one!
No!
We're looking for big bowls that can hold soup and vegetables and big things.
Stuff.
Yeah.
I know they'd also take us to the balls section.
No, I don't want a ball!
I want a pool!
But the balls we got, they're perfect!
Good size!
They're nice, they're kind of white, but not like hospital white.
They're nice and they're cute.
And simple.
Most importantly, they can hold lots of soup!
I think we're ready.
We got two.
Perfect amount.
Moco-chan, you're not gonna drop yours, right?
Actually, I was worried about dropping.
Please do not.
I guess if you drop it though, we could just order another one.
True.
But thank you so much, Ruffians!
Thank you!
Now we can finally have soup!
Yes!
Soup!
Oh my!
And we also got a nice big pot to cook the soup in!
We're now very excited!
Especially with all the yummy ingredients there are!
The four vegetables!
BAU BAU!
Yes, huge achievement!
Very much a huge achievement!
Did we surprise you, Ruffians?
With our big announcement!
I think head pats are in order.
Yes, they are.
BAU BAU!
It's a good day!
Yeah, a good way to start off the week.
BAU BAU!
Again, thank you Ruffians for the help!
Let's not look at balls so much longer.
Let's take a look at the Doggie of the Day!
Today's Doggie of the Day is...
Lady!
Look how comfy we are!
Look at that paw.
Kinda looks like it's just about ready to fall off there, huh?
It's dangling!
Yeah, she's just so relaxed.
I just wanna crawl up there with lady.
FUWAMOCO-CHAN WE GOT IT!
How does lady BAU BAU, huh?
Maybe it's sort of... BAU BAU.
BAU BAU.
I should not notice Moco-chan when you're having a good dream.
Maybe.
BAU BAU!
By the way, lady is super cute and also very neat.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Have a howl of a day!
That doesn't sound like a problem to us, you know?
And you know what?
We're gonna give lady lots of pets too!
So it sounds like a win-win!
Win-win!
BAU BAU!
Very cute lady.
Wow!
Ruffians!
Let's see where you've been going for walks recently, huh?
The day I went on a walk.
We have De-den!
What a nice morning!
Yeah, a beautiful sunset at the end of what sounds like it was a super fun day.
So nice!
We're really glad you know that you had a good time and go out and about there.
I feel like we're always so super lucky when we see a particularly beautiful sunrise or sunset.
It makes us feel so thankful for every day.
This is a really good one, huh?
I hope Ruffians that maybe the right sunset or sunrise will be beautiful just like this for you too.
Please take a moment for it, okay?
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
And next we have our Question of the Day!
Our Question of the Day is... De-den!
Hello FUWAMOCO!
Hello!
I have a question.
Pero is, like we know, a bit nasty.
But why did you decide to keep him as a pet?
BAU BAU!
This is a good question!
Ruffians, have you wondered this too?
You know, Pero, he's a pain.
He can say some nasty things, right?
A lot, yeah.
Yeah, and he can kinda be a bit scary towards the Ruffians, too.
There's been some close calls, huh?
Yeah, but, uh, you know!
He's Papa Puppy's friend!
Yeah, and, I mean, he didn't teach us a lot many dog years ago.
Yeah.
But you know, now he has no more new tricks to teach us.
He's just the old demon dog, you know?
Yeah, but he still doesn't go away.
So, just kind of make him our pet now, right?
Yeah!
And you know, sometimes he does help out.
You know, like getting us wifi and cell and stuff.
Yeah, that was day four.
Most of the time deshita is nasty.
BAU BAU!
Thank you Ruffians for your questions, your books, for sending us your doggies, and also your Pero Sightings.
Ruffians, we are always looking for more submissions so please, you know, we're so happy to have you here being a part of FUWAMOCO.
FUWAMOCO Morning.
But if you want to, it can be an even better part.
Just use the hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMorning.
And send us your Doggie of the Day, your questions, your looks, and your Pero Sightings.
We're waiting, okay?
BAU BAU!
Well, we have another stream coming up relatively soon.
Let's take a look at what it is.
We have...
Paratopic.
It's a horror evening, we're gonna be playing Paratopic.
It's a 3D retro horror game.
It looks scary!
Yeah, right!
I don't know what it's about.
Yeah.
Ah!
The pixels!
No!
Ah!
The pixels!
Pixels!
It's kinda, yeah, it's quite a face.
It's quite a face.
Yeah.
Does he look after a 12 hour shift?
No.
Be kind to yourself.
He looks much, much, much, much more frightened.
I don't know if he's a little frightened.
Maybe after a 12 hour shift.
Oh, that makes sense.
Yeah.
Anybody will be.
Let me get into bed, you know I'm tired!
I'm a little bit scared but also excited because...
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Have a howl of a day!
BAU BAU!
It's my schedule!
Well, Pero Talk, it might be one of the first horror games ever.
But it's not the first!
No, because we're continuing with 7 Days to Die!
A big big project project game that we're all playing together with hololive English for this next 7 days.
It says 7 days to die.
Like you have 7 days within those days to die, but what about 7 days to survive?
Huh?
Right!
We don't know.
I'm looking forward to it.
It's going to be our first time playing it!
And more than anything, together with all our senpais!
Our Iriankohai, too!
It's going to be a lot of fun!
Yeah, and you know, I'm sure we'll get to know each other very, very much.
Nice and close.
Especially since, you know, we're surviving together.
Things might get a little bit rough.
A little bit... gross.
Don't be sorry.
Why?
Yeah.
But we're gonna do our best!
And then, you know we have our off collab together with Patraresa.
And we also have Marin's brain...brain?
Battle.
Battle is right!
And on Sunday too, we have a members only stream!
We're gonna be playing Fall Guys together with the Doggy Pack!
So if you haven't played before, please go and download Fall Guys!
It is free!
It's super fun!
And we might be able to play all together too!
I hope that's the week!
I'm up next here.
Thank you so much for joining us, Ruffians!
We hope to have an even more fun week together!
For Ruffians who are joining us through the archive today too, here is your FUWAMOCODEword!
It's BAU BAU Brain Pirate!
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you for joining us today for this FUWAMOCO Morning!
It's not starting, it's ending.
It's over.
But before we say bau bau for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Haisuke!
BAU BAU!
Zakkou!
Maki-san!
BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!